[Music]
music is the key to a character or to
unlock your connection to story
[Laughter]
riveted by the portrait of a woman
unraveling but I was fascinated by the
script on a rhythmic level I had such a
propulsive quality to it so I think I
connected probably first and foremost on
an intellectual level I lent into it
just to try and speak Lydia tar's
language
[Music]
I think the demands of the role but also
the demands of the story that it would
ultimately make on an audience I thought
I really wanted to be part of that
conversation
you know as much homework as I did for
the script she ingested that script she
memorized it souped the nuts so by the
time we started shooting together she
knew everything that I knew and she'd
gone beyond what I knew
there's so many interwoven elements and
an audience didn't need to know all of
these terms because they got the sense
of the world it was an atmosphere
building the World building was so
complete
we were finding things together that
were were far beyond the material
she has an incredible sensitivity to
sound and that has been diagnosed as a
thing called misophonia you can fly into
a rage if someone across the room even
pulls out a chip packet because you know
they're about to make that noise
so a lot of conductors that I've spoken
to have that in one form of another
it was really important that we feel as
if we're immersed in this character's
process it's a process film it's a
rehearsal film
the difficult thing for me I think was
to find moments to allow an audience in
so they can connect with the experience
her brain is moving at a hundred miles a
minute I mean to to have all of those
thoughts but then also to be incredibly
conscious of the audience it's been up
your paddle to to get to conduct those
big pieces and you don't know what
you're capable of really until you do
because you can't practice that stuff at
home you know you the orchestra is your
instrument
the film is as much about the World At
Large as it is about the classical music
world
I think it's like so much more scope to
talk about so much more because the
gender was flipped you can talk about
power structures in a way that people
are much more open to receiving the the
Nuance of the film because it's not the
same old same old male situation
[Music]
she wants to be beyond that she wants to
feel like that doesn't matter anymore
I relished the whole process the journey
was really incredible